hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
the real crux of Hegel's famous
dialectic of master and slave which we
find in paragraphs 194 to 196 of his
phenomenology of spirit in the self
consciousness section consists in what
happens to and through the person who's
in the one down position the slave or
the bondsman is how it's sometimes also
translated the connect in in German as
opposed to the master who is in a
position of enjoyment who gets to
control who gets to set the slave to
work and who derives recognition the
slave is in a secondary and as Hegel
will say almost a derivative position
come compared to the master but here's
where the master-slave dialectic
radically reverses things and turn
things upon their head the master really
is not dialectically developing he or
she enjoys this position in which they
get the slave to work upon the world of
objects for them to transform those
objects into things of their enjoyment
there is no further development there
there is a development on the part of
the slave and this is what the entire
master-slave dialectic is is really
about you notice that I'm representing
this here by showing these these sort of
directions of you might say agency going
from the master to the slave and also to
the independent thing that has worked
upon and then there's this circular
current running through them and that
represents the developing
self-consciousness of the slave as an
independent consciousness no longer
merely dependent no longer merely a
reflection of the will of the master but
something that has been attained
something that has been achieved and you
notice I've got three things picked out
here fear service and work each of these
Hegel stresses plays a key role if you
have one of these without having the
others you don't really get the sort of
development that Hagel is taking place
and so for example he will tell us if
you don't have the right sort of fear
all you end up with is a kind of
stubbornness or or self-centeredness on
the part of the servant and not
something that is transformative and
leading to to a new type of
consciousness
so let's actually take a look at some of
the things that he says I'm going to go
through this text fairly quickly and and
not you know touching on every single
part but he says what we've got here is
is a servant or a slave who exists in
relation to the Lord or master that is
their essential reality and so the Eagle
talks here about the slave discovering
the truth of themselves and at first
they take the truth to lie in the master
the master is really the one giving the
truth to them as what they are
something like as Aristotle called it an
unsold tool going to work on objects and
transforming them for the enjoyment of
the master but something else is taking
place here so Hegel first talks about
the negativity that is involved on the
part of the the slave the negativity is
not just that they feel bad emotions or
that they they're deprived of you know
the fruits of their labor but the very
capacity for being otherwise is which is
essential to self consciousness is that
negativity there's negativity upon
negativity involved in the life and the
consciousness of the slave and that is
essential to what it means for Hegel to
be human being so he goes on and he says
one way in which this is experienced is
through fear he says this consciousness
has been fearful not of this or that
particular thing or just at odd moments
which could apply to the master - right
but its whole being has been seized with
dread it has experienced the fear of
death the absolute Lord the absolute
master who even the master
is subject to and here you said
something really important in this
experience it has been shaken to the
very core of its existence it is not
just felt a feeling it has had the
entire meaning of its world and of
itself and its existence called into
question and you know perhaps even
dangled in front of its face is
something that's being taken away from
it knowing that it could die at any
moment if the master or a masters kid or
you know some other master or some other
contingent circumstance decide so this
level of fear this extent of fear Hegel
says is necessary in order for this
transformation to take place so he says
what what's going on here this is a
universal movement an absolute melting
away of everything stable that reveals
to us the is he says essential nature of
self consciousness absolute negativity
pure being for self now he says this
becomes explicit for the the slave for
the bondsman for the Lord or the master
it exists for him as his object now is
this enough to simply feel fear to
produce the transformation and
self-consciousness that Hegel is talking
about here no these two other elements
are needed service and work so Hegel
will go on and tell us that this fear is
only implicitly this dissolution and
what we need here is service service of
who service of the Lord it provides a
certain sort of stability to the
instability that the fear he has he says
the fear of the Lord is the beginning of
wisdom but consciousness is not there in
aware that it is a being for self it's
not fully self aware through work he
says the slave becomes conscious of what
he truly is so the truth of the slave at
this point begins to no longer
lie in the master but in the work in the
thing the master is a consciousness who
sets the slave to work by making them
fear by giving them determinate things
to work upon the slave does service for
the master but the slave does that
precisely by turning to something else
the independent thing that has to be
worked upon whether it is mopping the
floor or doing the taxes or dancing in
which case it's your own body that is
the independent thing that you're taking
control over there's a subordination not
only to the master in service but to the
thing itself
Hegel goes on aney and he says that
desire has reserved to itself the pure
negating of the object thereby it's
unalloyed feeling of self the slave is
forced to put desire on hold
they cannot satisfy themselves think of
farming for example or even better since
this is something that we can all relate
to I think a little bit easier I think
about cooking when you're cooking for
somebody else do you get to sample the
dish as you're going through well you
may in fact taste the sauce a little bit
just to make sure everything is on track
but if you're making a nice little
cutlet for somebody you don't cut off a
little portion and pop it in your mouth
you you know if they're in the position
of the master and you're making
something for them they get the good
stuff and you'll get to taste it later
on
or perhaps you add it earlier in if
you're working at a restaurant with the
family meal or the crew meal beforehand
right but you have to put your desire on
hold anybody who's worked in restaurant
settings knows exactly what I'm talking
about you put your desire on hold for
hours and hours a very basic desire to
taste to touch to enjoy that is for the
patrons so work he says the desire held
in check fleeting the staved off work
forms and che
the thing that is what is required if
you want to form and shape the thing you
can't be enjoying the thing and by doing
this self conscious the self
consciousness of the slave is something
radically different than that of the
master it is getting to know itself
through the world of objects so Hegel
goes on and he says this is the negative
middle term or formative activity right
and he says in this way consciousness
qua worker comes to see in the
independent being of the object its own
independence its own independence
through working now Hegel towards the
end tells us he makes the explicit
connection that you have to have all
three of these he says you know we have
the the first moment the negative
significance of fear and then we have
service and then we have work and he
says in fashioning the thing the
bondsman's own negativity his being for
self becomes an object form only through
his setting at not the existing shape
confronting him but this objective
negative moment is none other than the
alien being before whom it is trembled
it looks at the thing as sort of an
extension of the master and it makes
itself nothing in in relation to it and
then he says now he destroys this alien
negative moment posits himself as a
negative in the permanent order of
things and becomes for himself somebody
existing at his own account in turning
to the object that I'm doing I'm working
upon because the master put me to do it
and I'm serving the master and I'm
afraid of the master by working on the
object I come to realize that the master
doesn't have the power that I took them
to have a total power over everything
they are restricted they don't actually
know the object I know the object
because I work on it and I transform it
and I am a slave in that case in a
certain sense greater than the master I
develop a consciousness of myself
through
doing this as I said Hegel stresses that
all three of these moments need to be
here he talks about this as a
rediscovery of himself by himself
and he says in the work where I seem to
have only an alienated existence where I
seem to be set at odds with myself to
not actually possess myself this is
where I acquire a mind of my own and he
says the two moments of fear and service
and such as also that a formative
activity are necessary without the
discipline of service and obedience fear
remains merely formal it doesn't
accomplish anything
it doesn't transform it doesn't develop
without the formative activity the work
which is also service for the master
fear remains inward and mute
consciousness does not become explicitly
for itself
if however consciousness works on the
objects without feeling that initial
fear then it doesn't have this
transformative experience according to
Hegel and it represents mere sort of
stubbornness or a kind of selfishness on
its own part of self-centeredness you
could you could say so he says if it's
not experienced absolute fear but only
lesser dread so it's substance has not
been infected through and through so a
determinate being still in principle at
at attaches to it having a mind of one's
own is self will a freedom still a
meshed in servitude so what we have here
is in Hegel's view something that occurs
not in every condition of servitude but
only when the conditions are actually
right and when those conditions are
actually right we have a transformation
a higher development a sublation
of consciousness
you